on attendait l'événement depuis
plusieurs jours un chamalières beau
match de football entre les commerçants
de la ville et l'équipe du conseil
municipal avec le maire de tête bien sûr
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
fidèle au rendez vous de ce dimanche
matin la foule était là également pour
un mille personnes au moins lorsque les
équipes se présentèrent de quoi faire
rêver le trésorier du club de football
chamaliérois et commerçants à droite en
première mi-temps était bien décidé à ne
pas s'en laisser compter par le ministre
des finances et il dominait ce début de
match après cette attaque spectaculaire
tant et si bien que le premier but à la
tête à leur actif et ce malgrès une
tactique défensive efficace du capitaine
de la mairie
encore un coup on avait joué 15 minutes
mais elle comptait bien triste pour les
22 acteurs pourtant dans la bataille les
troupes du ministre des finances
égalisant peu après l'heure c'est un but
partout les commerçants faisaient le
forcing à nouveau il allait reprendre
l'avantagé juste après le but
égalisateur
on s'acheminait donc vers une défaite
des élus mais coup de théâtre à une
minute de la fin à la suite d'une action
confuse devant les buts commerçants
l'arbitré accordé un penalty à la mairie
le premier magistrat n'a laissé à
personne le soin de faire justice
quand on veut par tous les deux équipes
avaient pourtant bien gagner une bonne
douche
tu ministre nous avons écouté dire que
vous avez profitez de votre voyage à
reykjavík chez monsieur nous ne sommes
pour prendre des prisons football est
malheureusement en france a bien voulu
mais est bien que le président pompidou
qui soit descendu chez lui nous avons
entendu un interview à la radio à la
veille de notre départ et on disait en
effet que ce chapitre est chez lui alors
je t'ai dit lui demander conseil et
passeront de ce match et puis finalement
une prison pompidou ce qui fait que je
n'ai pas pu avoir les derniers secrets
de monsieur kinshasa oui mais enfin vous
voyez à mon avis à une graine de nos
footballeurs en herbe dont franck lebon
plus qu'on ne le croit j'étais frappé de
voir sur le terrain la qualité de la
ligne devant de nos adversaires
ces commerçants n'ont pas été trop
coriace m'aviez vu que c'était un match
assez dur il ya eu des heurts n'ont pas
été très corrects et germain gaiffe la
foule auvergnate est revenu sur le terre
dans un bon esprit
vous avez réussi le penalty qui a fait
le match nul
cette équipe était menée 2 1 je pense
oui alors nous tenions beaucoup s'il
voulait a toujours pas nous faire
enfoncer ont marqué un petit à petit du
tome 2 des recettes se fait
naturellement fin comme dans ont pu
égaliser juste avant la fin qui reste
plus qu'une minute et demie à jouer
après ça de mon jeu défensif pour garder
d'égalisation à s'imposer est comme ça
tout le monde est satisfait exactement
il fallait quand même con marqué plus de
parts et d'autres parce que sinon on
aurait cru que nous n'avions pas joué le
tel esprit sportif de 2 c'est une mort
qui t'a fait classique d'imbaba ce
football
vous n'avez pas l'intention doivent
persister dans l'équipe de chamalières
cela ramènerait beaucoup de monde
non il ya très bons joueurs du bord en
réserve et là c'est parce que c'était
l'équipe du conseil municipal mais rien
ne démontre quel conseil municipal ne
vois pas d'autres initiatives de ce
genre dans l'est